[Music]
I think that was emily gould co-editor
of the world-famous website Gawker calm
you might be wondering one lying on the
floor of my living room wearing a
beat-up seersucker suit and looking as
if I've was recently rode hard and put
away wet
it's because I was up very late last
night attending the young adult
literature prom welcome to rock it's the
social event on the young adult
literature calendar
[Music]
but boy heck it took it out of me yeah
alright fate in your eyes it's been a
long night my friend and now I've got to
go to Mobile Alabama by the way I didn't
know that reducing your carbon footprint
meant eating unheated food in that case
I'm not reducing my carbon footprint at
all I'm just not turning on the lights
unless I really have to the prom last
night wasn't bad for my carbon footprint
though there were no lights at all look
I don't want to get on an airplane today
I don't want to go to an airport I just
want to stay right down here
[Music]
it's so nice why can't I just stay like
this all day
I'd be so happy anyway Hank the music
wasn't as good as it was at your wedding
but it was fairly good like it's always
nice to hear the Mickey song
[Music]
Oh
Oh Hank when people asked me why don't
you love New York it's because when a
man is trying to sleep in his brand-new
seersucker suit there are car alarms
going off at the ungodly hour of 1025 in
the morning
[Music]